I am your lord then I will Diamond hands
your coin bow to me why are you making
so many excuses bro why because oh you
know him you're cool you're cool with
him you're a contact FIS you're in
contact with him is that why double
standards and
hypocrisy just imagine the people back
in the day when they would have to
travel certain distances for months or
even years what is one thing that they
would carry with them the Quran why
because they did not have it on their
mobile devices or their gadgets brothers
and sisters imagine you have a app the
Quran app which not only shows you how
much rewards you get but reminds you to
read the Quran gives you reminders
download the Quran app now and let it
testify for you on that you read it
wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends so Andrew Tate obviously makes
controversial statements uh but when he
is obviously a Muslim and with Islam
Islam is very to the point Allah is
clear who Allah is to us it's not like
the Trinity the Quran is clear it's not
like the Bible the prophet Muhammad PE
be upon him his position is clear is a
prophet not like Jesus in the Bible Etc
and you know and people just can't
casually come and insult and add things
and take away we have the Quran the
Sunnah and the the salaf we have a clear
methodology clear science alhamdulillah
nobody can come and add and take away
stuff aldah of course there differ opin
certain matters but that's a different
story here so in this matter who is to
blame there's a few things I'm going to
touch up on why because the statement
that he made was the following which is
that obviously brother J came out as
well and I I watched his video as well
he's very frustrated and I'll be honest
with you I understood his frustration at
the same time I want to come from it
from a different perspective cuz I've
been a Muslim for 11 years so I know how
long it took me to come you know get rid
of certain bad tra and we know from the
evidence from the Hadi of the Prophet
mammed when they were going to war and
some of the companions actually said to
the prophet PE can you make us a tree
there was a specific tree where certain
would go and hang their swords for some
blessing or whatever it is the shy stuff
going on and some of the companion came
to the prophet mammed PE if I'm not
mistaken in the Battle of H if I'm not
mistaken yeah so they were heading there
and they asked the prophet can you make
us a tree La this and the prophet PE
upon him said the things of jahil of
ignorance hasn't still left you the
statements was made to by the prophet
mam to many people when they said
statements of racism and stuff like that
which shows that they are still
Believers and that's why Allah says in
the
Quran Allah differentiat between a
Muslim and a every mmin is a Muslim but
not every Muslim is a mmin that's what
Allah says to the beds in the Quran that
do not say that you have believed rather
say you're a Muslim meaning you've
submitted Iman comes after so now here
is the statement that he made which was
say it again without the effort say it
properly with respect I am your lord
then I will Diamond hands your coin bow
to me so now obviously from an exor when
you're looking at this obviously it it
looks problematic we cannot clearcut
come and say this is sh it can it can
you can insinuate that now obviously the
people come and say you know brother you
know the Sal would say if we saw our
brother drenched in alcohol we would say
somebody poured over their head if we
saw our brother in the mountain saying I
am your lord and you are my slave he
will say he's reading the vers of the
Quran can we apply this here I would you
have to be fair and say no not really no
we cannot yeah because why because
Andrew has been for a good couple of
years and at the end of he's our brother
yes and we will defend his honor cuz the
Sharia calls us to defend it however
when the however when the Sharia calls
us to now you know give our brother the
s or be firm with him this this this is
what we will do so I believe that
there's some brothers who came from an
angle where it's firm and I believe they
should now Andrew obviously brought a
clarification which was that he said let
me clarify there's only one God Allah
the king of the Lord I am from the
street some terms are used as referrals
to being a boss stake on my behalf I
fear no man of critism apart from Allah
alhamd now of course like reading this
look I'll be honest with you obviously
there's some V language there ET but say
it properly with respect I am your lord
we know look there's a brother in
Birmingham that we know he is but his
name is Lord Alim yes being a lord
doesn't necessarily mean the Lord that
you're talking about you know okay like
Jesus when he was accused of claing to
be God he said do you not say ye are
Gods with a small G okay so I think the
benefit that could be given um then I
will Diamond your hands hands your coin
bow to me bow does not me necessarily
mean worship cuz we know that the Angels
bow will prostrated to Adam Alam yes but
we do not say that they were worshiping
so benefit of Doubt can be given however
Andrew T has made M statements now one
thing I want to say is who's responsible
for this and also those who are making
um extra good assumptions for their
brother which is a good trait but
funnily enough these very Brothers
especially I'll mention one of them
Farris um this is specific individual
why because when I had a debate with a
scumbag dirt apus the scum you know who
you are yeah and I proud of it alhamd
and I am proud of it yeah capital
punishment alhamd i' been watching
popcorn I am proud of it alhamdulillah
in an Islamic country legally yes
nothing Bounty hun none of that nonsense
of you know some are going to n we're
we're not about that alhamd yeah now
when I had a debate with him and in that
debate I was I did some cringy stuff and
I admit it was very cringy it should not
been done it it it was not it was not
nice there was nothing Haram there was
nothing that I said against the dean
nothing to do with Miss quoting or
saying something sh this guy came at me
like and I never knew about him he came
who is this guy giving da he doesn't
know how to give da about me you don't
know nothing about me I know Ali need da
but come on on matters of whenever ever
made a mistake I can human being slip
Up's tongue but I'm saying when but why
don't you come out and say something
about Andre tape what about other
brother speak call brother you're
defending him yeah you call everybody
innovator you you're disqualified you
cannot call anyone innovator you're
don't even qualified to do that but when
it comes to this you make hundred
excuses why are you making so many
excuses bro why because oh you know him
you're cool you're cool with him you're
in contact FIS you're in contact with
him is that why double standers and
hypocrisy and I blame these people who
are next to him that you are the ones if
you are close to have communication with
him you should be educating them you
should be speaking to him you should be
informing him not they're taking
pictures Etc yeah first you say you
don't take pictures of celebrities and
then I think youal opportunity so the
point is that as new Muslims you need to
understand there were traits that eye
was left if I used to carry you know the
Turkish blue eye in my car yeah I used
to do stuff like this touchwood I did
was new Muslim he looked at me said what
are you doing I said I don't know I just
just a habit yeah those blue eyes was I
didn't know it took me time I didn't do
it intentionally of course when it's in
the public sphere these things can
happen so what do we take from this
brothers and sisters the thing that we
take is very simple and clear that I
believe that some people come and say
he's been a Muslim for so long how does
he not know certain basic things true
it's a it's a it's a valid like Jake
brother Jake may Allah bless and preser
please go subscribe to his channel
amazing brother what he said there is
there's validity to that but I would
also say from a different perspective
that let's try to be a bit more patient
and one thing that I want to say is this
all the brothers that are watching the
level that you have if this was a sister
I have to be just yeah I don't take
sister or brother side with this
anything anyone that knows me knows me
yeah if that was a sister who had been a
Muslim for that long and she was showing
her hair or showing a bit of her thighs
or was showing let's not say thighs
let's say her carves or whatever her
legs or arms or whatever you guys will
be going ballistic you guys will be so
much issues that is a sister who's
showing her statements or you know the
statements that could you know be like
hold on a second you make 100 excuses
one billion excuses I'm just showing the
double stand in hypocrisy I'm not having
to go brother Andrew yeah even though I
believe he should know better with the
statements however still give bit better
doubt you guys would go crazy why for
the level where is your level for for
Allah's Wess where is your where people
this kind of statements are made yeah or
like for example Christ is King again
look I defended them sneak on was Etc
where is it when is a sister she shows
one strand of hair you go crazy
ballistic but when it's a brother who's
a new Muslim you give him EXT no Allah
says in the Quran speak the truth even
if it's against yourself so this is why
brothers who are watching this when it's
a new Muslim who accepts Islam a sister
she does anything like this you are on
her case you make her life living hell
instead of giv it a simple genuine n
privately ET whatever okay it can be
done publicly as well but when it's a
brother who does you know something sh
some sh statement there looks a bit
weird there igu Etc good assumption good
assumption good assumption good
assumption why don't you apply that to
your sisters why don't you apply that to
the sisters why don't you apply to the
sister who's maybe struggling with hijab
it can be normal it can happen by the
way it can happen it's understandable
but you have more two the sister's hair
sh ET then you've got problems bro you
got problems okay you have not
understood this is what I'm going to say
and brother sisters we should have more
to Allah's than anything else in again
because he's a new Muslim I would say
please my dear brother Andrew please be
careful inshallah and I believe he
should be invited to more Muslim podcast
and speak to him inah and that's what
I'm going to say may Allah bless
preserve you guys inshallah and he's
given a clarification and again I think
we should give him this last personally
for my side is this is subjective good
assumption in in this but obviously if
it's a reoccurring pattern then there
has to be some changes and people who
are around them need to in inform them
and educate them in because the basic
things like brother Jake said I tag this
video as well which you should watch
it'll be a fine balance to see from my
side and from his side till next time